at-elle nafti il était céiste hauteur de
tunisie dessine-moi une révolution
publié chez l'harmattan
bonjour à thème nafti merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur ert france cas
quand le président tunisien de ce sommet
alors la tunisie a embourbé dans une
crise économique sociale doublée de la
crise à lithaire donc le président
attend certainement de un besoin de
financement il vient le chercher ça
s'inscrit de toute les façons dans de
ceux dans ce sommet où ils représentent
au delà de la tunisie je pense qu'ils
représentent tous les pays du maghreb
parce que sur toute l'afrique du nord il
ya la tunisie et l'egypte donc c'est
dans ce cadre que s'inscrit cette visite
si une dette publique tunisienne qui a
quand même hâte en 81 t'est 11,8
milliards de dinars en 2020 c'est
environ 27 de 6 milliards d'euros selon
la banque tunisienne est ce que qu'ils
essayaient tu peux espérer un prêt pour
relever l'économie tunisienne
c'est ce qui est généralement attendu de
ce genre de de ce genre de sommets ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que depuis
la révolution de 2011 et notamment il ya
exactement dix ans le sommet de
deauville du g7 et beaucoup de 10 ont
beaucoup de promesses qui n'ont pas
toutes été concrétisé donc les tunisiens
sont quand même assez échaudés par
rapport aux grandes déclarations qui
ceux qui sont pas forcément suivies
d'effet vous vouliez c'est aussi en
sommet qui se tient pour réagir aux
chocs économiques après plus d'un an de
crise en tunisie un programme de relance
post coronavirus a été préparé par le
gouvernement une participation est
également attendu par cas et sayed à son
à son financement
oui certainement parce que au moment où
nous parlons se tiennent
depuis maintenant plus de deux semaines
ceux qui se tiennent des pourparlers
entre le gouvernement tunisien et les
représentants notamment du fmi sur les
financements de besoins de financement
de la tunisie et le propositions de
sortie de crise tel qu'entendu par les
grands bailleurs de fonds notamment le
fmi donc généralement c'est une aide qui
est conditionné à ce qu'on appelle un
plan d'ajustement structurel donc à une
série de mesures et de mesures
économiques et disons le mot un
programme d'austérité en contrepartie de
l'échangeur fin en contrepartie du
soutien de ses devoirs des bailleurs de
fonds notamment la famille vous restez
sur l'impact de la crise sanitaire
comment dans quelle mesure le le coc u19
à affaiblir l'économie tunisienne
l'économie tunisienne est très
dépendante du tourisme donc s'il ya eu
une première vague en 2020 donc juste
avant la saison touristique
une première vague qui était très très
bien maîtrisé il ya eu une cinquantaine
de morts sur toute la première vague dès
le mois de juin
on a connu un été où il n'y a quasiment
pas eu de mort ensuite par contre ça
repris
donc il ya déjà eu une première saison
touristique qui a été fortement affectée
donc celle de 2000 jean et celle de 2021
intervient dans un cadre où la
l'épidémie beaucoup moins maîtrisée en
tunisie et
et où la vaccination traîne énormément
par rapport à des pays comme le maroc la
grèce ou l'italie qui sont les
principaux concurrents de la tunisie sur
sur le secteur méditerranée est donc le
tourisme étant plombés par par
l'épidémie l'économie s'en ressent
forcément et en plus par ailleurs il y à
une crise politique très importante
entre les deux têtes de l'exécutif donc
le gouvernement et le président de la
république qui ne facilite pas forcément
les choses
une dernière question à thème nafti
selon les informations de jeune afrique
du matériel à oxygène mais aussi
justement des vaccins dont vous disais
qu'il y avait un manque en tunisie
pourrait être proposée par emmanuel
macron est ce que vous confirmez cette
information ces rumeurs alors c'est
effectivement d'aider à lens en a eu
plein d'allant ce qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément été qui n'ont pas forcément
été concrétisées et
encore une fois ci ce sont des vaccins
qui sont conditionnés à certaines
réformes imposées par des institutions
internationales voire même à des à des
positionnements politiques et
géopolitiques la tunisie est
actuellement membre de du conseil de
sécurité représente les états arabes du
conseil de sécurité
donc ça peut être aussi des vaccins en
contrepartie de pression sur la position
tunisienne par rapport à la guerre que
mène israël sur la bande de gaza merci à
thème nafti on comprend donc des
attentes plutôt mitigé pour ce sommet je
rappelle que vous êtes essayiste auteur
de tunisie dessine-moi une révolution
publié chez l'harmattan merci à vous